are you mrs. money who are you my friend
any cuz I really need to find them I
can't help you I haven't seen my son in
two years
it took all my money okay I don't know
who you are this [ __ ] name tattooed
on my hand so what you're looking for
money
what about like five bucks oh my god are
you housekeeping yes this is manifold
can you watch her for me I don't know
much about kids so it's too much for me
nobody ever tells you how hard it's
gonna be I see all these women have TV
in the street and they're doing it like
hi Margo and Steven I spoke with Larry
Daniels he says you've had the papers
for a while down but I don't mean to
rush you just sign the papers
I need to find a girl I'm a girlfriend
Tallulah miss Barry Buzan it is
what's your plan Luke did you have a
plan my plan list should be married to
have a family
how'd that work out I guess it didn't
they both left me
I'm Louisa kidding and the Child
Protective Services can we get a stick
in my heart
if you are in trouble it's okay this is
your family
when I was six my mom sat me up on the
stoop and told me to wait I never saw
her again I just think it's better to
not be needed that's no way to live she
needs you
and I grew up and hate you and it really
blows your mind it's super sad kiss a
stranger
you're fine thank you